DIDN'T INVADE ANY COUNTRIES
ZONE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS WITHIN
OUR BORDERS.
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND, IT
ENDED THE YEAR WITH 343
MURDERS OR 56 FOR EVERY
100,000 PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE CITY'S HIGHEST
PER CAPITA RATE EVER.
GREATER EVEN THAN DURING THE
GREAT CRACK EPIDEMIC, THE
SAD EPIDEMIC OF THE 1980s.
ONE OBVIOUS CULPRIT FOR THIS
STAND DOWN BY POLICE AFTER
THE 2015 RIOTS THERE
FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF
FREDDIE GRAY, BALTIMORE COPS
WERE PRESSURED TO BACK OFF
ON TOUGH POLICING TACTICS.
A LOT OF THEM AFRAID TO GO
FOR THE MOST PART THEY
BACKED OFF AND THIS IS THE
RESULT.
WITH DON JONES CRIMINAL
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
BALTIMORE WHO ARE NOT RIGHT
WINGERS WHO ACTUALLY LIVE
THERE IN CONTRAST TO A LOT
RICH KIDS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
WHO ARE SAYING THAT THE
POLICE LEAVING HAS BEEN A
TRAGEDY.
THIS IS THE REFERENCED SCOTT
ACTIVIST IN THE CITY QUOTE
WE WANTED THE POLICE THERE.
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN A CITY
WITH OVER 300 MURDERS WANT
POLICE KEEPING ORDER?
YOU.
>> WELL, THEY ABSOLUTELY DO.
THEY WANT THE SAME THING YOU
TALKED ABOUT IN LAST FEW
SEGMENTS.
THEY DON'T WANT GOVERNMENT
OVERREACH BY HAVING POLICE
OFFICERS WHO ARE ABUSIVE TO
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
ROLE AS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Tucker: I THINK EVERYBODY
WANTS THAT FOR SURE.
AND I AGREE WITH THEM
COMPLETELY.
I HATE ANY ABUSE OF POWER,
WHETHER IT'S BY THE COPS OR
DMV WORKER YOU DEAL WITH OR
ANYBODY.
ABUSE OF POWER IS ALWAYS
WRONG.
THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER PEOPLE IN
BALTIMORE WERE SAYING.
IT WAS THE COPS ARE THE
PROBLEM.
THE CITY IS A BAD PLACE
BECAUSE OF THE COPS.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, THERE
WERE THREATS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE POLICE PHYSICAL
TO PUT YOUR REPUTATION ON
ARGUMENT.
AS A WHEN YOU HAVE A
THANKLESS JOB VERY HARD TO
GET UP THE NEXT DAY AND DO
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
WHAT'S WHAT YOU SIGN UP FOR.
I DON'T THINK THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER STANCE LAST
TIME I WAS ON THE SHOW YOU
SAID I WAS A BLACK LIVES
MATTER ACTIVIST.
I'M NOT AN ACTIVIST.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT PEOPLE
HEARD.
WE DON'T WANT THE POLICE TO
KILL US, WHICH IS A PRETTY
DIFFERENT THING.
>> Tucker: THE WHOLE LIKE
PIGS IN A BLANKET, MURDER
COPS STUFF THAT'S THE
NUANCED MESSAGE THAT YOU ARE
DESCRIBING?
THE WHOLE CITY OF BALTIMORE
OR THE ENTIRE BLACK LIVES
MATTER ANY MORE FAIR THAN
WOULD BE TO SAY THAT EVERY
WHITE PERSON IS WITH THE KU
KLUX KLAN OR NEO NAZI.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: WHOA, SLOW DOWN.
THAT WAS AT A BLACK LIVES
ON VIDEO.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE I'M MAKING
ARE DETRACTORS THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO TRY TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THE REAL CHANGE AND BE
DIVISIVE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MISLEAD.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT IN EVERY
WAS.
BLACK LIVES MATTER IS NO
DIFFERENT.
BUT, ANYONE WHO REALLY LOOKS
AT WHAT THEY STAND FOR, WHAT
THEY PUT OUT.
WHAT THEIR LEADERS EXPOSE IS
REALLY GETTING TO THE 21st
CENTURY POLICING AND MAKING
SURE THERE IS NO GOVERNMENT
OVERREACH.
>> Tucker: YOU KEEP CRUISING
THAT TRAYS
THAT PRAYS
THAT PHRYS
AGAINST ANY GOVERNMENT
RECOVERY RECOVERY REACH.
2017, 333 MURDERS IN THE
CITY OF BALTIMORE WHY IS
THAT.
>> I DON'T LIVE IN BALTIMORE
ARE A NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT
GO INTO THE INCREASE OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE THINGS
THE THINGS THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER ASK AND MANY OTHERS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITY NOT AGAINST THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY HAVE NOT
REACHED THAT POINT YET.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, I'M
CONFUSED YOU SAY YOU ARE
PART OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
AT LEAST SYMPATHETIC TO IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT BUT
YES.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE MURDER
VICTIMS WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED AND
CONFUSED BY WHY YOU WOULDN'T
LIKE IT'S A SERIOUS
QUESTION.
WHY WERE 343 PEOPLE MURDERED
IN BALTIMORE THIS YEAR.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT WHY?
ABSOLUTELY BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY ONE ARGUMENT
HAS TO DO WITH THE OTHER.
ALL LIVES DO, IN FACT
MATTER.
WHETHER THEY ARE TAKEN BY
THE HANDS OF THE POLICE OR
OF CRIMINALS, I THINK PEOPLE
BOTH OF THOSE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE EITHER
OR.
>> Tucker: LOOK, BLACK LIVES
COPS ARE THE PROBLEM.
I DON'T HEAR ANYBODY EVEN
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
DIE IN A SMALL CITY AND I
NEVER HEAR ANYBODY SAY WHY.
TUCKER, I HAVE A HARD TIME
BELIEVING THAT YOU REALLY
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH BLACK
LIVES MATTER TO KNOW WHAT
RIGHT NOW AND I CAN'T GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER WHICH A
LITTLE BIT REVEALING.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
TOLD YOU WHEN I CAME ON I'M
NOT A BLACK LIVES MATTER
ACTIVIST BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
WHY IT'S AN ISSUE.
ALL AMERICANS, I WOULD HOPE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
WE ARE ACTUALLY SAYING THE
SAME THING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHY I'M
DOING THE SEGMENT.
I WANT TO GET A REAL ANSWER
BUT I'M NOT GETTING ONE.
>> THAT'S THE ANSWER.